Welcome to "Ear Biscuits,"
a podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at "The Round
Table of Dim Lighting,"
we are kicking off-
"Sex Timber."
Timber.
Oh, that's good.
Have you done that before?
"Sex Timber.
Men, we're having an
incredible conversation
with a qualified professional
who knows all about sex
more than just a couple of
boys have been having sex
with the same ladies for
a long, for a long time.
And before you give Emily's
bio, just wanna say,
hey, this podcast and this
iteration of sex timber, 2022,
may not be for you.
So use your own discretion
if you want to keep
listening the disclaimer is-
Well, you gotta wanna say why, why.
The reason why, is
because we talk about...
We talk very specifically and explicitly-
Explicitly.
About sex.
Okay?
So we're not holding anything back,
we're not beating around the bush.
Well, you're all ready done.
Men, we're all there.
So proceed informed,
make an informed decision if
you wanna be a part of this,
but I gotta tell you,
if you're up for it, this could be...
This could be really encouraging.
It could be really enlightening.
It could be really educational.
I think it's a great
conversation.
It could be really exciting.
And we're breaking down the stigmas.
We can talk about sex.
Yeah.
And we don't have to-
Not just in September, but
that is kind of what we do.
We don't have to apologize for it.
Right.
So give the bio and then
let's get into it with Emily.
Emily Morse is a doctor of human sexuality
and a sex therapist.
She's recognized as one of today's
most insightful sex educators,
challenging cultural
taboos, misinformation,
and awkward sex talks.
Love it.
To create a future where
people can deeply connect
and shamelessly embrace pleasure.
Love it.
She's the host of "Sex With Emily,"
a podcast that's been
going for a long time.
2005 is what she told us.
And it might be the
preeminent sex podcast.
I'm gonna say that it is
the preeminent sex podcast.
She's inspired millions
of people to normalize sex
and pleasure by creating a safe space
where people can explore.
And that's exactly what we
did with her in this episode,
we explored many topics.
Yeah.
Right off the bat .
Here it is.
"Good Mythical Evening"
has been rescheduled.
You can still watch it, you
can rent it on Video on demand,
that will be available
from September 12th,
through September 18th.
You can rent it up to 9:00 PM, Pacific,
that's midnight Eastern,
and then watch that rental.
So get in on the action.
Goodmythicalevening.com.
It's really happening this time.
Yeah.
Emily, thanks for being here.
Thanks for having me.
Now we talk about sex
one month outta the year,
you talk about sex all the time.
Yeah.
Well, speak for yourself, man.
You talk about...
Okay, I mean off the show,
we'll talk about sex.
And publicly, every once in a while I-
You just go out in public
and talk about sex?
On the street corners, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
So okay, yeah.
Good for you, man.
Well, okay.
I'm not gonna assume
that you know anything
about our background,
but I'm just gonna-
Okay.
So one of the reasons that we waited
to talk about sex publicly is our very...
We come from a very conservative,
evangelical Christian background
that we have since exited that world.
Okay.
And of course, so there was a lot of like,
"Hey, if we're gonna talk about sex,
you gotta talk about it in
the right context, et cetera."
And so it took us a while to
get to a place where it's like,
"Hey, let's just rip the bandaid off
and just tell people that this
is actually how we think."
And it's been incredibly freeing-
Yeah.
To be able to discuss this stuff.
But we haven't ever really discussed it
with a professional before.
Okay, I think it's time.
We're just going off our experience.
It's time.
And all our experiences
with one woman each.
Oh, with your wives,
with your partners.
Yeah.
That's right.
Well, especially, well that's
thanks for that background.
Because growing up in
an environment like...
Lemme just say this,
most people on planet are not comfortable
talking about sex.
It makes them uncomfortable.
Obviously, they're not comfortable.
There's a lot of judgment,
there's a lot of fear,
especially who grew up in
very religious backgrounds.
I think a lot of my listeners
are people who are either
still in that space, or have
moved beyond that space,
or left that space.
But it's still like,
how do you start talking about something
that was so demonized your entire life?
And now we're gonna talk about it.
So it's mixed messages.
And then no matter where you grew up,
society doesn't actually
welcome it with open arms.
There's so much misinformation about sex.
So it's just...
I'm just glad that we've
all arrived here today,
is what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But I get why it's not easy.
We're countering that,
now with just being
totally open and saying,
"Hey, I think there's a lot of health,
and just putting it out there.
And that's why I just wanna
start by jumping into orgasms.
Oh, okay.
Can we talk about orga,
orga, all types of orgasms.
I wanna have every type
of orgasm that can be had,
and that's what I wanna-
I'm sorry Emily.
That's what I want get outta this-
But you know what?
There's no shame in asking that question,
but it's just the way you
framed it when you said,
"I wanna jump into orgasms."
That was how you...
You could have said,
"Let's talk about orgasms."
Yeah.
Is there a jumping orgasm?
Can I reach climax by jumping?
No.
I do think one of those
little trampolines,
like the little exercise trampolines.
If you jump on one of those
long enough and hard enough,
I do believe you can
have an orgasm on one.
Really?
I do...
Yeah.
I mean, you could probably
have an orgasm anywhere
if you really wanted to.
But sure, that would be
an interesting place.
But I don't think we should jump,
here's the problem with orgasms.
We think we should just
be able to snap our hands
and jump right into orgasms,
but it takes a little bit of warm up.
Right.
Something called foreplay.
Yeah.
Something called
understanding the orgasm.
I know that part of most part.
I'm just saying,
when it comes to...
I mean, I'm not gonna
have an orgasm right here.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna have a
conversation about it.
Right.
Exactly, cool.
'Cause that's a whole different show.
I don't wanna-
That's not even my show.
I wanna learn about new
orgasms and then I wanna...
So that I can experience it.
What do you mean?
Well.
New?
What do you know?
Yeah.
What do you think he means
by new orgasms?
Unclear, 'cause here's the thing.
I always wanna meet
people where they're at,
and I'm not sure how much,
what you know about orgasms.
What's new to you might
not be new to someone else.
Do you wanna-
Well, I've had a...
I've had an orgasm with my penis.
Okay, that's great.
That is a penile orgasm.
Yep.
Okay.
That's an orgasm.
That's a real orgasm.
And I love it.
I had one of those as well.
I'm a big fan of those.
Right?
They're a good time.
I don't know what other types there are
that I could have.
Okay.
Yeah, that's why we get into that.
Especially because you
guys are in male bodies,
'cause you have penises.
Yeah.
I can say all the things here, right?
Like really-
Oh, yeah.
Like that's a clinical term,
you have a penis.
So people of penises,
they can also have something
called a prostate orgasm.
Because men have a prostate,
and so that's through your anus,
there's this wonderful
little walnut shaped,
bunch of clumps of nerve endings there-
Yeah.
That you could find
about two inches inside
with a finger or toy.
And when penetrate-
Two inches inside your
butt there's a walnut.
Yeah, about two inches.
There's a walnut, yes.
Kinda like a walnut.
You don't even have to
eat walnuts to get it.
Wow.
I've heard about this,
this is a good one to start with
because I've never had one of these.
But I did have a friend one
time who told me that if I...
That I should...
He described it and I
was like, "Oh my God,
I gotta have one of these."
Yes,
Are you talking
about the milking, the
milking of the prostate?
Yes.
Is that what
you're talking about?
Yes.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
What is it?
What is it like?
Okay.
What do you do to the walnut?
Okay, so.
You said two inches?
It's about an inch.
Yeah, and you should have
two, you gotta find it.
Kind of find it yourself,
or someone could find it for you.
But it's sort of like, you
could put a finger inside
and it takes a little bit of practice,
but it's like a come hither motion
towards your belly button.
And it's similar to how to find a G-spot
on a female partner.
Okay.
In the sense of
it's that same motion,
like towards the belly button-
Yeah.
I don't know why my hands are like this.
Yeah, put 'em away-
I'm too,
I'm showing you.
Put 'em away.
And so yeah, that how you find it.
And so what happens is it's
sort of responsible for...
Yeah, it can help.
But the amazing thing about it,
the reason why you don't
know about it is because
there is a lot of people who believe
that if they ever explored that area,
the prostate and what could feel amazing,
that it would somehow
define their sexuality.
Like maybe it'll make me gay.
Right.
Maybe it'll be people think things.
And I don't think that the
gay community particularly
has a lockdown on the prostate market.
It just means that they like discovered it
in other ways that we feel shame about.
But I'm telling you a sex
tech doesn't make you gay
if you were into it,
which I hope that you
might be after today.
That's amazing, and there
has to be some exploring
and some hunting around.
But once you find it,
it can feel incredible.
And it's sort of stimulating
this different part.
So it's different than
your regular orgasm.
Okay.
It's different than orgasm of your penis,
'cause you're stimulating the prostate,
which is like seminal fluid
in it and what you kind of,
it feels different, but
it can feel incredible.
So for the majority of penis owners,
as I call them on my show,
they say that it's a very intense feeling
that they feel throughout
their whole body.
And it's a little bit more intense,
and yeah, not-
More intense than a-
Yes.
I was gonna say a normal orgasm,
but I don't wanna say that 'cause that's-
Okay, well
Than a wiener orgasm.
I didn't know-
Way more intense.
I didn't know I was gonna have to go here
so early in this conversation.
If you're about to tell me
that you've had one of these
and you haven't told me about
it, I'm gonna be pretty mad.
I don't tell you everything, man.
But this is...
If this is like a earth shattering orgasm
and you're like keeping it to yourself.
I had to talk to another
friend who told me about it.
I think I know who you're talking about.
So, okay.
Well, you tell me this,
what I'll say is that I
don't necessarily think that
my wife and I have figured out like the,
what you might call the
milking of the prostate,
but isn't there a similar...
Is that a thing?
Oh man.
Did he just make that up?
I wasn't.
No, I'm looking the prostate
stimulating the prostate.
I'm glad that I did not think
about this ahead of time
because-
Does milk come out of it?
Is seminal fluid, dude.
Seminal fluid.
Comes out of...
Comes out where?
Okay, do you know?
Yeah.
It produces the fluid in semen,
but it's like the size of
the shape of the walnut,
but there's also this seminal
fluid that comes out of it.
Like, so when you say-
So you ejaculate?
Hold on, let me.
Yes.
I know a little bit about this.
We used to call it pre...
When we were growing up, right.
You remember that, especially
when you were a teenager
and you were hanging out with a hot girl,
spending time with her
and then all of a sudden-
Spending time with her.
You get home.
And for me, I honestly
didn't even have to,
nothing had to happen.
Sometimes it was just like,
something could happen
and just the thought of
something could happen,
you get home-
Yeah.
And you look in your
drawers and you're like,
there was some stuff happening
where I was getting ready for this, right.
That's seminal fluid,
right?
Yeah, yeah.
You've experienced?
Yes.
That's right?
So yes.
I love that by the way.
So here's what I will tell you,
and I'm trying, I can't.
I thought we would warm up to this,
but you're the one-
No men.
Who decided we would get-
Jump into it.
We jumped into orgasms .
This is not sex, this is
conversation about sex.
We got to jump into it.
So I have experimented with a butt plug.
Nice.
Yeah, nervous laugh.
Great, very...
That's a great way-
Is this surprising to you?
It's offensive to me.
Why is it offensive to you?
Because you didn't share it with me.
I'm not gonna share my
butt plug with you, man.
Like that's unsanitary.
You're not even really
supposed to share it
with your partner, unless you
like boil it ahead of time.
A boiling butt plug.
That sounds like torture.
No, you wait for it to
cool before you insert it.
I meant share the experience,
not to experience.
Like loop me in like an email.
I know.
An email would be nice.
The correct term is lube you in, actually.
Yes.
Because lube
is very important.
Now, okay.
Just like a DM.
Just anything, it's like a text maybe.
Emily, so-
Ask me about butt plugs.
What I'll say is that
this this intrigued me,
this intrigue me a while ago.
I think the first time
I experimented with one,
I think it was probably 15 years ago.
I was still very much like
a evangelical Christian conservative,
but my view towards sex in the
way that my wife and I think
about sex has always been very
open and kind of adventurous.
But it was kind of like, I don't know,
kinda makes me feel like I'm
having about to take a...
And I didn't know how
to really embrace it.
So it hasn't been something
that has happened.
But you purchased one.
Yeah, yeah.
And you plugged your butt with it.
Yeah, with the very small one, yeah.
And then you didn't come
to work that way, did you?
No, but I know from
listening to Emily's podcast,
that there are people who will go to work
and wear a butt plug all day, right?
Yeah, some people.
You learned that from
people probably called in
and asked how long is too
long to wear a butt plug.
I mean, it's not a common question,
but there's some sanitary issues.
So I wouldn't wear it all day long.
Just like anything,
you probably gotta
change it after a while.
Maybe a few hours is max,
but some people really love the sensation
of having something.
And this goes for all genders.
It can feel really hot
to have something inside of you all day,
because there's all these nerve endings.
I think we need to break
down why it feels good too.
Okay, yes please.
There's so many nerve...
Are you still okay?
Are you recovered from the fact
that Rhett didn't share this with you?
Are we good to move on?
Yeah.
I mean, just to use an analogy,
I feel like we jumped right into
this sex timber conversation.
And I was thinking that I was personally,
like proverbially gonna
be lubed up a little bit
before I put the butt
plug in, so to speak.
Yes.
And I just feel like you
kind of forced me into
it to be flank with you.
Sorry.
And there wasn't consent,
there wasn't consent.
I just said, sorry, I'm just asked,
that's literally where
I left that statement.
I don't know why I meant to say,
asking the penetrating questions.
Yes, but what I will say,
which I think is what you're
getting at here Emily, is that
there's a point in which you're like,
I understand the additional sensation-
Yeah.
That this offers.
The additional seminal fluid
that this offers the situation.
It hasn't been the kind
of thing that like,
I know just from reading
that there are some people who are like,
"Hey, once I went back...
Once I went to that, I never went back
and I always have went in
every time I have sex."
That's not my experience,
but I definitely think it's
worth experimenting with,
and there might be some benefits.
So Emily.
I can send you a butt plug.
We can talk after the show.
Hold on, do you have like-
Is that merch?
Do you have like a-
Merchandising?
Do you have a proprietary butt plug?
Yeah, no, but I get so many sent to me,
prostate toys to test.
Oh, we know he'll test 'em all the time,
but you don't even have to
report back just as a gift.
My gift is you.
Okay.
Well, it seems like I'm
the one who needs it.
Does the butt plug stimulate the prostate?
Yes.
And so it gives you
a prostate orgasm.
Okay.
I always want my assistant to write,
'cause we actually record in my house
that she can almost like
go run and grab a butt plug
and a prostate toy.
Yeah.
Yes please.
To show you, 'cause we're on video.
You know where they're, they're actually-
Jenna, Jenna is our assistant.
Jenna, can you run and
grab Rhett's butt plug?
Do you know about this?
Yeah, I know exactly where it is.
That is the first...
We gave Jenna a mic, that is
the first thing she ever said
that she knew where Rhett's butt plug was.
They gave me a mic for a vulva,
a person with a vulva's
point of view on this end.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Yes.
Good, I'm so glad you're here.
I'm so glad you're here.
Truly, truly.
But anyway, where were we?
So yes a butt plug is great
and that can be used all genders,
butt plug can put inside
and it feels great.
Because there's so many
nerve ending right inside,
like a butt plug might only
go in like an inch or two,
which I know that said
that's where the prostate is,
but it's a little bit harder
to find with a butt plug.
A butt plug will not necessarily stimulate
the entire prostate,
however, a prostate toy,
which is shaped like the
internal part of a prostate,
like your prostate, is
a little bit longer.
It has some vibrations that go inside it.
It can also vibrate.
Oh.
Here we go.
This might be your...
Oh, I dunno if any
these are prostate toys.
Oh, they're not prostate toys.
Let me-
It might be hard to find the tantra.
is so funny.
What's the line?
They're like black.
Okay, let me find them.
And they...
I don't know, we'll
have to point, but sure.
But this is okay.
These are all the butt plugs
I just happen to have in my storage.
Is that just a big box or
is that a big butt plug?
Or does that have a remote control?
Yes, you guys so much happened
in these years.
Holy...
I'm telling you, Rhett since
you used your last butt plug,
you guys, I can send whatever
you're interested to.
They also don't come in pink
if you want like a black one
or a blue one.
But this is one by We-Vibe,
but they has a remote control.
There's other ones that you
could use with your phone,
where it digitally, like
you could send your partner-
You can make calls with the butt plug?
I'm not gonna listen.
I'm not talk...
I am not talking to my
mom through a butt plug.
If my mom calls me up while
I've got that thing in me,
I am not answering, okay?
No, I recommend...
That's a strong no,
but you can have your partner
control it from a phone.
What happens with...
It just vibrates?
So some of these vibrates
someplace, some don't.
But you put 'em inside
and it just sort of like this one is a...
This is by We-Vibe, it's like a...
It's called the Ditto.
And if this one does
vibrate, it goes inside,
and this part also here goes inside.
But this stimulates the peroneum,
which is like the taint,
the taint, like a taint-
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
You know what the taint is?
Taint your ass, taint balls.
Yeah.
And they say this part is
really sensitive to men too,
like right before the...
Yeah, the taint, the area right there.
So if this goes inside
of you, this butt plug,
then right here, this also vibrates,
and you can just kind
of push it up against.
It's like everything
that you put in your butt
should have a flared edge.
Yeah.
It should flare.
So you don't get...
It doesn't get lost.
So this is the flare-
So you don't have to go
to the ER and be one of those stories.
You don't wanna be on the show,
"Sex Seminar of The Year."
Yeah, right.
Unless you do
wanna be on that show.
I don't.
Do any of these products,
'cause I think where we might be able
to really get Link involved in this,
do any of these remote control butt plugs
also double as like a Bluetooth speaker?
No.
Because I feel like
if he could pump hip hop to his ass.
Wait, yes.
This is the kind of thing
that he would love.
That might be your entry point.
I think a tribe called quest.
Well, the entry point is
the anus, I understand that.
There is another company that makes one
that you can set to your playlist
and it will vibrate
along with your playlist.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Okay, thank you.
Good job.
So tell me how to use this thing.
Let's just play exactly.
I'm getting really overhead
here on all the things.
So what you do is, you...
So this is just a pro...
Okay, so this one is the prostate toy.
Can you see this?
So this one.
So progasm 20 anniversary.
there's so much tech.
You guys, I'm obsessed with this brand
because Aeros knows all about it.
So this one looks a little bit more
like your prostate, right?
Like this one fits in
a little bit more snug.
Okay.
But I recommend
for any kind of anal play,
starting with something a little
smaller, like a butt plug,
Okay?
Okay.
How you start is the first
thing I would recommend
if you haven't ever even
ventured into that area,
then maybe when you're
having your alone time,
if it's your masturbating or
with your partner, your wife,
to first just explore anal play,
like what does it actually feel like
even to have a finger outside of my anus?
Because there's a lot of like muscles
that feel really great,
like the sphincter muscles
are very sensitive in that area.
Like you don't wanna go from
zero to anal is all I'm saying.
You don't wanna-
Yeah.
Let's build up.
That's gonna be the name of
this episode, "Zero to Anal."
You're welcome.
Yeah.
That's exactly what we did.
Yes.
So you wanna start out with fingers,
maybe your own fingers or
your partner's fingers.
You wanna always make sure
that your hands are clean.
Your fingernails are trimmed,
you or your partners
or probably everyone's,
and you wanna use a lot of lube,
'cause the anus is not self lubricating.
So you wanna make sure you
use lube and you explore,
and you think like, whoa.
And you just kind of maybe use a finger,
what does that feel like
to even have something inside of me?
I wouldn't go from like zero
to like a bigger toy at first.
So you try that out and you go very slow
and you communicate
well with your partner.
And you're like,
"Oh, that actually does feel
good or might feel good."
And then you can graduate to a butt plug.
Again, you put that in slowly.
There's a ceremony when you
graduate to the butt plug,
there is a ceremony, there's
a tassel and everything.
Yeah.
Just so you know.
I can send you my...
I can send you my gown.
Okay.
Will your mom be at my ceremony?
Yeah, my dad will be filming it
with this little video camera too,
because he films all my graduations.
This will be one he's never like the legs,
he's never seen.
Is there-
Question for you Emily?
I wanna know, is there any other prep?
Because once I started to
talk about the good stuff,
I don't want to have to go
back and talk about the-
Make sure that you're
about empty, about empty.
Make sure that you don't need
to go to-
Go to bathroom.
Well, here's the thing,
hygiene...
So let's just...
We can talk about all the
worries that people have
and that's one of them like-
Yeah.
First is like,
is it gonna make me...
People will think I'm gay if
I'm not gay or nothing matters?
That's bull...
Yeah, we're over that.
You're beyond that, thank God.
Okay, good, okay.
The other thing is about-
We know what makes you
gay and it's who you are.
Yeah, it's who you are, who you sleep with
perhaps would make you gay.
Yeah.
Not a toy.
So after you've feel good about that,
the hygiene part is about just
like cleaning out your bowel,
like cleaning.
I mean, if you know when
you've gone to the bathroom
and you haven't,
so typically not most of us.
Sometimes.
Sometimes, as I get older,
it's harder to figure out.
Let's not...
I want to hear this part, but
I don't want to dwell on it.
Okay, go ahead
We're gonna go very quickly-
This is a barrier.
This is a barrier for me.
Empty the bottle or not.
Okay.
Okay, so we're
gonna talk about it.
So you know, you know when
you've gone or you haven't,
if it's been 12 hours and you've gone.
Let's say, you know this
is my natural bowel cycle.
Okay, .
I've got do that to my pier.
You're pretty much fine-
Yeah.
If it's like,
"Oh, I had a really big meal last night.
I had lots of beans, rice, whatever.
I haven't gone yet."
Not the best day to try them.
Right.
But there's also
the .
Is there any more...
Okay, so is there any more...
Is there another level of clean?
Okay.
I'm a fan of cleaning
all types of things.
Matter of fact.
Okay.
But my problem is I clean things too much.
Well, this is okay.
Again, I happen to listen
to the right episode.
And first of all it's very
fresh in my memory, but-
Oh yeah?
I love this.
The doctor that you were talking to
the first half of the anal episode,
he has his own, essentially
he has his own anal...
What's it called?
Feature, what's the name-
Yeah , feature method,
Dr. Evan Goldstein.
Yep, feature method.
Yep, I have a...
I can't even...
I have a .
Oh.
Well, that'll take care
of some of it, but-
Some of it.
See, here's the thing, is that...
Okay, so I actually talked...
I think I talked about
this on the podcast is that
maybe I didn't.
Well, but we're already here so.
Every once in a while I told you,
'cause you do the same thing.
There's been a couple of times
when you're about to travel,
I know when I'm about to travel.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
I'm gonna be on a plane today.
I've gotta get on...
There's a connection.
I don't like on a plane...
Or really at an airport.
Oh yeah, yeah.
So it's just like-
I'm a big fan of like-
Do a little enema.
Enema.
But the travel-
Oh.
I have to travel with an enema
'cause I get all clogged up.
Oh, perfect.
So here's the thing.
I'm totally good with it.
I love an enema.
Hold on, but see,
I'm pulling you back from that
because what I learned on Emily's podcast
from the doctor that...
What's his name?
Dr. Evan Goldstein.
Evan Goldstein.
If you're just using like water
or it's like a traditional enema solution,
you're actually like taking
things out of the lining.
That's like a protective lining.
So he's got some like pH
ballot, special blend.
Okay.
He's got a proprietary-
Some guy's trying to sell
me something, I get it.
But also he is...
But lemme tell you
this, you don't need to,
you could go to the grocery
store, you go to the store,
wherever you buy your enemas,
and you could buy the enema
that comes with the vinegar.
Pour out all that vinegar, don't use that.
And then just use the
hot water and do that
and then flush it through
your system one or two times,
so you feel everything's out.
Okay, I'm good there.
That's easy, right?
Just do that.
And then you have
confidence.
You don't need vinegar.
Yeah.
That it's not a question.
So you've done a little
anal play is what I hear.
I mean, if you wanna call-
Well, it's always felt like
an emergency situation.
I know, but I'm saying that like,
I would say that you are...
And I'm not speaking for all men
or all men who grew up in our environment
with our background, but
we are all uncomfortable
with the idea of like...
Right, but-
The dukey shoot as you call it.
The fact that you are doing an enema,
a pre travel enema and
then talking about it
on the internet, you're
way ahead of the game.
Yes.
right.
You're ready to go on to middle school
and then the graduation
into the butt plug zone.
But the question-
I'm gonna lap you buddy.
This is not a competition.
The question I have for you, Emily is
how do you address couples
or people in general
who are like, man...
We aren't even having
sex on a regular basis
or we're not even talking about sex,
or like we do it the same
way every single time.
So like we are seven layers removed
from butt plug graduation mode.
Right.
What do you think is the key to...
Because I think that the
thing that we find is that,
when you just talk about this stuff
and you start exploring
it together as a couple,
there's a world of fun
that you're just leaving on the table
if you are just like, this
makes me feel uncomfortable.
And I'm not trying to shame anybody
who may not be as comfortable.
You don't have to be
comfortable with all this stuff
that doesn't make you normal
or abnormal or whatever.
But if you kind of are interested
and you want to do this,
but the idea of broaching
this topic with your partner
is something that makes your sphincter
completely shrivel up.
How do you address those people?
Hmm, such a good question
because more I would say again,
I love this question because
this is the challenge.
Most couples have a hard
time talking about sex,
and most couples in
long term relationships
have gotten or have gotten,
or will get to the point
where sex has become
kind of mundane, rote,
a little bit stale and maybe
they even stopped having sex,
and they literally don't know what to do,
how to talk about it,
or where to start again-
Yep.
To bring back that spark.
And if you haven't talked about sex
and nothing's been happening a while,
again, I probably wouldn't go
from not talking about sex to anal.
I would probably start in another area.
Yeah.
And so I would recommend
is really just I've these
three Ts of communication.
And they've helped many, many people.
And it's timing, tone and turf.
Because what I found is that we don't know
how to bring this topic up.
Maybe you want more sex than your partner,
or maybe you both realize
it hasn't been happening,
yet, you really don't
know how to talk about it.
And you keep hoping it
get going to get better
or one day our partners gonna come home,
be like, "I'm ready."
Or it's just dead, it's just died.
And the first thing I
wanna do is normalize that
for every couple that is in
a long term relationship.
I hate saying every, 'cause
it's like, "No, we haven't,"
fine, but the majority,
99% of couples gonna get to a point
where they get into a sexual rote.
And that's because we
don't talk about sex.
We are not comfortable with it.
And we assume that when there's
a problem with our sex life,
it probably means either like,
we shouldn't be together anymore,
it's something I did wrong,
I'm no longer attractive,
my partner doesn't find me attractive.
And we create all these
stories on our head.
And since we don't have
a lot of great examples
of people talking about sex,
we just decided to say nothing.
So with timing, tone and turf,
which is a great way to have it.
You've never...
I'm gonna assume for the
majority of the listening,
it's gotten stale or for you guys,
maybe I know you didn't say that,
but you're not really
sure how to broach it.
And so we need the timing is
when you are just hanging out,
you're not halt,
I like to say hungry,
angry, lonely, or tired.
So make sure none of those
things are happening,
but you're in a good place.
Chilling-
I'm always hungry though.
I know, well, one of them, at least.
You're not so hungry that
you're gonna be cranky.
Got it.
So that's the timing.
It's not gonna be after the
last time you got frustrated
that the sex didn't happen
and then you're like,
"Why didn't it happen again?"
No, it's that time.
Yeah.
And then your tone
is compassionate and it's curious.
And it's like, "Hey, I realize
that we haven't talked about
our sex life in a long time.
And I realize that we probably both
wanna be great lovers to each other.
So maybe we can start to figure
out ways to talk about it.
And I'd letting you know
that I'd love to find ways
so we can both get our needs met,
be wonderful lovers to each
other, have more satisfaction."
Got it.
And the conversation
just goes from there.
And then the tone, the turf
is outside the bedroom.
Many couples think that the conversation
should happen in the bedroom.
'Cause if you were talking
about like a recipe,
it would happen in the kitchen.
But the bedroom, I believe,
deeply believe it should be
for sleeping and for sex.
So to have the conversations,
when you're like on a road trip,
you're hanging out together.
You're just in a good mellow space-
So you're on my side,
you believe no talking in the bedroom?
Yeah.
Yeah, not about these things.
You can dirty talk in the bedroom.
And at what point do you reveal
that you've had a butt
plug in the whole time?
Well, if it has a tail.
That's up to you.
If it has a tail on it-
Oh-
Which I haven't done that
you can do that.
You can get 'em with tails.
I have-
Oh, like a furry tail.
Yeah, a furry tail.
Yes.
Oh.
Yeah, I haven't done that yet, but I feel
after this conversation,
I gotta do something.
If you yank on it,
does it make raccoon sounds?
You don't want to yank on it.
Just a little...
A light tug at most.
Okay, okay.
All right.
Yeah.
That was very, very helpful.
That question-
That question was very helpful,
but honestly it just
wasn't juicy enough for me-
Okay.
What's another orgasm
that I can have.
Oh, we're back to orgasms.
Okay, another one that you can have,
or that your partner can have.
Yeah, let's focus on what our
partners gonna experience.
Okay, let's talk about the partner.
Okay.
So what kind of orgasms do we
know about with our partners-
So you've got the clitoral orgasm,
and then you've got the vaginal orgasm
and those are different,
even though the clitoris can
extend all the way inside,
depending on the person's anatomy.
Right.
It goes further than others.
So I'm familiar with these concepts.
Good, I love this.
We're so good.
So there is a clitoral orgasm,
which we all know the clitoris,
know is 8,000 nerve endings.
I'm actually gonna show
you another prop here.
Oh, you got-
We've got a-
You got a clitoris puppet?
Yes, please.
Oh, I do have.
I wonder what voice
she's gonna use for it.
Oh, that's a good point.
Hello, this is your vulva.
No, I think you need to go again,
like go like Oscar-
Oscar the Grouch, Eor.
No, we don't wanna be-
Oh my God,
not hot Oscar the Grouch.
What does he do?
Oh, he's voice is the cookie,
if that's a cookie monster.
I don't know if I can make all of it.
I don't think I can
break Oscar the Grouch,
but you guys can narrate the, the vulva.
No, you do it.
Don't let no.
I'm the left vulva.
Are you the right one?
Yes.
No, I'm not...
I'm not getting-
You'd be the right vulva.
I'm not gonna be one half
of a vulva puppet with you,
I'm sorry.
Look up here in between us.
Look at that man in the boat.
Yeah, that's good.
Good.
Good job.
Although there's only one vulva.
Oh.
There's only one vulva,
but you could be the
labia, there's two labias.
Oh yes.
See, look at that.
You could be the left-
Yeah, these are right and left vulva, men.
I'm the left labia.
So Let me just say this,
the vulva is referring to the
external part of the vagina.
Yes.
Which a lot of people
interchange them vagina about-
Listen, I am guilty.
You know this.
What I said last year,
and I've tried to take
responsibility for this, but...
Okay, so we talked a little bit about
my spiritual background,
but I said that I thought
that the best evidence
for the existence of God
is the vagina, right?
Is my favorite thing in the world.
And then everyone went on to tell me that
what you're really talking
about is the vulva.
Yeah.
But it just sounds when
you say it in the context
of like a colloquial,
like philosophical thing,
it feels like I know
I'm technically wrong,
but when you say vulva,
it kind of sounds like in that context,
you're trying to like prove
that you know all the terminology.
But when the doctor
is talking about it-
Why can't you just be wrong?
Just be wrong, dude.
I said, I'm technically wrong.
No, just be totally wrong.
But I'm spiritually right.
Okay, the best existence,
the best evidence for the
existence of God is the vulva,
there I said it.
Okay, great.
I love it.
And the clitoris and...
I'm with you.
Great.
Good.
You're gonna tell me that the clitoris
has more nerve endings
than the head of the penis.
I've heard that.
Nice.
Yes, in fact, the clitoris
has 8,000 nerve endings
and the penis, circumcised
penis has 4,000.
Whoa, man.
From an evolutionary standpoint,
it's weird that it's separated
from the insertion point,
because it seems like...
Again, just evolutionarily speaking,
if you're thinking about
procreation that the most...
The insertion of the penis
into the vagina should...
Why aren't the nerve endings down there?
I wonder.
This is such a good question.
I am so glad you brought it up.
It's because we've been told,
and you guys might be familiar
to this from your upbringing,
that sex is all about procreation.
Penis goes into vagina,
we are procreating.
Sex happens, baby's born.
And that's the only time
we should be having sex.
That is the marketing machine behind sex
that it's procreation.
But what we've come to find out
is that the truth is the
majority of people with vulvas
will not have an orgasm with penetration
for exactly the reasons
you're talking about.
Because when there is a
penis going into here,
it is nowhere even scraping or
saying hello to the clitoris.
So the majority of women,
and I would say only 25%
of women have an orgasm
with a penis in their vagina.
Yeah.
So procreation,
I mean, so penetration
was all about procreation,
and otherwise you were ashamed
if you had any other kind of sex
in many places in the world.
Well, and also in me in media,
everything we grew up watching-
Yes.
It was just, oh, okay.
So when you're having sex with a woman,
like you're thrust-
You're thrusting.
And then eventually she
has an orgasm from this act
and you probably have
it exactly the same time
if you're really good at it.
Yeah.
And so that was the thought
that we all brought into-
Yeah, fake news-
Our sexual experiences.
Fake propag...
Yeah.
It's fake sexual propaganda,
was all about that.
So what I'm saying is, but
here's what I wanna tell you.
The good news is, so let's just say like,
these are the labias,
this is the clitoral hood.
This is the clitoris.
But just so you know,
what I think you mentioned this earlier
is that it has 8,000 nerves.
Well, you did mention that,
but it's not just this little bulb.
Do you know that the clitoris has legs
that extend deep inside?
So here's the actual clitoris,
and it goes behind this structure.
So this-
Looks Like a wishbone.
Exactly, it's a wishbone.
And this part right here is the clitoris,
but everything else is internal.
So those 8,000 nerve endings
are right behind the labia.
See what I mean?
Whoa.
And so when you are stimulating
it here, that's great.
But it's also stimulating internally,
all these areas that feel good
with the legs of the clitoris.
Okay.
This is the clitoral legs, yeah.
Has legs.
I think that answers,
if I go like purely scientific
and evolutionary theory here,
the developmentally,
the clitoris is comparable
to the head of the penis.
But then as a human develops,
it either turns into a penis
or it turns into a clitoris
and everything else-
Based on hormones
in the process.
Exactly.
And I do think that what...
So maybe from an evolutionary
standpoint that the clitoris
has gone down there-
Yes.
More than I realized.
More than you realized.
Yeah.
Penis and the clitoris
are analogous, truly.
And I don't wanna...
I wanna keep giving you merch ideas,
but I just had another one,
I think you need to start
selling the clitoral hoodie.
Oh.
I mean that just-
I Love that.
That just feels like
it's gonna sell itself.
Yeah.
I mean, it doesn't have...
I mean, it's just a
hoodie with maybe like...
Maybe there's a cool sort
of abstract clitoris design
on the back or the front.
So you don't really know,
but you just on your website,
it's the clitoral hoodie.
I also think
that Doctor Emily
could sell a travel pillow
that is shaped like a clitoris.
Like this is the entire clitoris.
Yep.
And then you wrap it
around your neck and it's
a great conversation piece.
You're always educating.
And then you're sleeping.
What better way to sleep than
being wrapped in a clitoris.
Great.
Swaddle with your clitoris, right?
Yeah, I love it.
What are we...
what do I...
What can I do that I haven't been doing-
Well, but before you get there-
To the clitoris?
You didn't like that question?
No, no, because I don't
wanna leave this subject yet
because first of all, I'm gonna have to...
I mean, my wife is fine with
me talking about a lot of stuff
while obviously have to ask her,
I'm gonna go ahead and
just disclose some things
and then I'll ask her before
you release this episode,
if this was okay.
Perfect.
But so I think she is
typical of a lot of women
in that the I would say,
every orgasm has been a clitoral orgasm,
but there has been over the past 20 years,
there has been the quest for
the vaginal orgasm, right?
Which is like, oh, I think
it's about to happen.
Oh, is it?
Oh, is it gonna happen?
And so what do you think about that quest?
Is that something that...
Is it something that
you should just abandon?
Is it something that-
No.
Okay.
No don't ever abandon
the exploration of your bodies.
And there's a lot of different theories
around the internal
orgasm, AKA the G-spot.
In fact, I sort of don't
even think it's a spot,
I think it's more like an area.
And I also think that
a lot of it's connected
to the clitoral legs.
So when you go inside of here...
Well, first lemme tell
you this, it's very...
The easiest way or the
one of the first steps
to actually having an internal
orgasm or G-spot orgasm
is making sure that you have
a clitoral orgasm first,
that you're already stimulated,
you're already turned on
because blood becomes more on gorge,
if it's swollen, you get turned on.
And then you're more likely
to be able to find the G-spot,
which much like the prostate
is about an inch and a half inside
using your fingers in
a come hither motion,
trying to find this little rough area,
which could be like the G area.
So that's the spot.
And it helps again to be aroused,
and then you just kind of
use that with the finger
and just kind of penetrate to feel around
and apply pressure and
see where that goes.
It could be a blended orgasm too,
when she already has a clitoral orgasm.
So it's just easier to
have like a blended one,
so it feels like all of them,
and again, for some people...
And I believe there's too-
I love a good smoothie.
A blended smoothie, a
blended orgasm smoothie.
Yeah.
Why not?
They sell that at air one, I think.
Or they should be I dunno.
It's way too expensive though.
And you gotta give 'em that-
Yeah, yeah.
But yeah, so no.
I think that with toys, and with fingers,
and with talking about it,
I think that many, many women
can find this elusive G-spot,
but orgasm.
But it's not gonna happen
through a penis for many.
Like if it hasn't happened
yet after 20 years,
this has nothing to do with your penis,
it has everything to do with the anatomy.
If you put a hundred women in a room
and you looked at all of them
touching themselves, let's say,
they were all like doing the thing
that makes them feel good.
They'd all be doing something different
because our vaginas, our
vulvas are like snowflakes
and they're all different.
So every single woman
needs something else.
So it's a little-
Blurr, that's cold.
Blurr, gotta warm it up.
It's like a snowflake.
Well, in a room full of dudes,
you'd see him doing different stuff.
We knew a guy in high school
that did two hand thing like this.
He would make...
He did that kind of thing.
Yeah, he did.
Remember when you told-
Well, we didn't witness it,
but he did choose to tell us.
No, but he just told, I guess,
one of those conversations
where everybody was disclosing-
He made it-
And they were talking about-
The double hand diamond.
Yeah, well, Link admitted
that he uses his left hand,
which is just another piece of evidence
that he's lefthanded.
He also holds a microphone
with his left hand.
Sorry, if you didn't want me to share that
we could edit it out.
And then another friend
talked about the double thing.
So I mean,
guys do it in all kinds
of different ways as well.
Guys do it all different ways too,
you're absolutely right.
You're absolutely right.
And so we all do it
differently, but how fun...
And I also recommend current
couples to do this together,
like a mutual masturbation sesh
is a super hot thing for couples to do,
to be like, I am gonna look at what I do.
I'm gonna turn myself on,
you're gonna turn yourself,
you're gonna do your thing,
and then I'm gonna like...
There's two reasons why I love this
because you're gonna see
what turns your partner on,
and that's really hot to
see them touch themselves.
But you're also gonna learn, like,
what do are they actually doing?
How do they touch themselves
if they mustabate?
Which I hope they do.
Yeah.
And then you just learn,
you learn and you just slow
down and it's a process.
But if it hasn't happened all these years
and there's nothing wrong with you either,
because again, the
majority of women are not,
and it has to do with their anatomy.
It has to do with biologically speaking,
how closely their vaginal
opening is to their clitoris.
And for those women,
they're more likely to
have more internal orgasms.
But for the other ones,
they got experiment with
there's some great toys,
fingers, taking the
pressure off, experimenting,
and having a clitoral orgasm first.
Those are my best
recommendations for that orgasm.
So I'm trying to think, what else,
what else is there down
there that can be splined,
squirting?
Let's talk about that.
Okay, is like-
What's my question here?
Is it pee, and does it matter?
Is it pee?
Thank you, thank you.
That's a top question.
Okay, well, first of all, squirting,
I did a show on squirting.
If wants such...
Check it out "Sex With Emily."
Can you imagine this?
It's like the most popular
show I've done in 20 years.
But I had a squirting...
I mean, people just love
talking about squirting,
but what it is?
It is liquids for it's
periurethral fluids.
There are traces of urine.
They have done studies of women
who completely empty their bladders,
and then they happen to orgasm,
and then yes, there's still urine in it.
My answer to that is, so what, who cares?
Does it feel good?
Throw a sheet down.
But there's a lot of
debate, like, is it pee?
Is it whatever?
So I don't know, if we wanna
spend time there great,
but I don't think it matters.
But what I can say is that
for many women they can squirt
or female ejaculate by
stimulating the female prostate,
which we also have one as well.
Where is that?
The female prostate is sort
of inside the vaginal...
I think you guys should
just listen to this show
we did with Deborah
Sandal who like in the 70s
started teaching women to squirt.
But the prostate is like,
once you get aroused and
then gorge, like I said,
it's like a little area
right behind the vaginal wall
where you might be fighting
looking for the G-spot.
Okay, so still on the front-
And you can see it,
and it swells.
Still on the front side.
Okay.
And it swells,
and eventually that also
has prosthetic fluid in it,
and when stimulated a woman can ejaculate.
Now, here's the thing about ejaculation,
it can feel amazing, like
an incredible release,
but it's not necessarily...
You can squirt and that orgasm,
you can orgasm and not squirt.
So I think that squirting
became really popular
during like with the advent of porn
or with porn being
available in our pocket-
Yeah.
In our pocket all the time.
And seen time to see so more,
so many more women squirting.
So I just have gotten
so many more questions
about it since then,
but it's definitely like
a fun thing to explore.
You could help your partner
do it using fingers,
or your penis, or a toy.
And really, it just comes
from continued pressure
to that internally pressure,
pressure, pressure,
feeling a release, and then
she can release and learn.
I think that many women
can learn to squirt,
it and just take some time.
Practice.
Because it gives you this...
It's a different type of...
I can relate to it because
with an ejaculation,
there's a sense of completion.
Is that...
Would you describe it in that
way, as such as completion?
Well, I would describe...
It is not necessary completion,
so what I was saying for many women,
they have one and they just feel released
and it feels really good,
but it's not necessarily an orgasm.
Now, some women have it
alongside their orgasm.
Like they have it with it,
or, I mean, they have it with
an orgasm and they squirt,
and it's just different for
all different kinds of women
to say, if they would
define it as completion.
But they might define it as
just like a really intense release
that could be kind of emotional, physical.
And once you know that it is a possibility
and you have experienced it,
it can be this thing where,
well, we gotta go until that happens
because that's the...
I think that's kinda
what you're getting at-
Yeah.
Like that's the sign that-
Is that the definition
of success?
The did has been done.
We all get to define
what success looks like
in a relationship and in orgasm.
That's why I hate to put labels on it.
It's like, was it success?
How did your partner feel?
Did she feel good, bad?
Did she feel like it
was a pain in the ass?
Or the pain in her vulva?
Did she feel like it wasn't
like a fun thing to do?
That's to me is what successful sex is.
Or did we talk about it?
Did we both get our needs met?
Whatever our needs were that day.
Was there some aftercare?
We cuddled after, we talked about things.
To me, that's a successful rock.
Okay, well, let's talk about missionary.
Not just because we
used to be missionaries,
which is no exaggeration.
Could I inter...
I just had one thing.
Okay.
Yes,
Jenna has something.
Jenna, where have you been my whole life?
Yes.
I was like,
hey, one thing to go back with squirting.
Well, the first thing with that was,
there's such an interesting,
'cause I am a vulva owner
who has squirted in the past.
And I think one of the things
that's so interesting about it
is there's a weird mix
of, oh, that's so amazing,
and shame as well.
Like I totally have been
with a partner before
and I have squirted.
And then my partner was like,
"Oh gosh, what is all of this?"
And it made me feel like what...
It was like the...
And it was early on in my sexual
awakening, I suppose.
So still trying to feel comfortable.
So I know a lot of other
women have experienced that.
I'm also one of the 25%
as well, who can do...
Who can have the vaginal,
but that was something
that I learned on solo,
trying out things with myself-
Masturbating like that.
That was like in my own sexual awakening,
separate from a partner.
But then-
Yeah.
When you having those discussions
with partners now of just like,
you're gonna be chilled
with all this stuff, right?
Right.
Like this is a good thing.
Yeah, I'm so glad you brought this up.
You just brought up like
so many great points.
The first thing is that like,
yeah, a lot of us have
been shamed by a partner.
That's I once had a partner who's like,
I remember like I got
my period or something
and he was like, "Oh God,
we gotta change the
sheet, to take a shower,
and like call 911."
I'm like, are you...
Kidding me?
Like, .
So then we get shame,
I'm like, I have to put
blankets down and sheets down.
And there is that partner
who shames us all the time.
Like, it's a mess.
And yes, I've had guys
call in and be like,
it's a mess and I don't want it.
It's fine.
And I think throw a towel down,
throw a beach towel
down, like do something.
There's some there's throws
that are just made for sex
because sex can be messy.
I think if they're not preparing it
or maybe they're a little OCD,
like that just rocked their world.
So I am sorry you got shamed
that way, but I just...
Again, yeah, we wanna move
on to partners that are like,
bring it, like messy and hot
and sex is all those things.
And those are the partners
that I choose to be with,
but yeah, we all have people
from the past that were like,
that was not a good lesson that learned.
Not a good message that they sent me
'cause now I feel shame about it.
But hopefully we can move on from that.
Was that...
I mean, were you surprised at that time
or were you like, this is...
You're...
Oh yeah, I was super surprised.
It was the first time that
it had happened for me.
So I was also like, what?
So you both surprised?
And 'cause I didn't really watch porn,
so I didn't know necessarily
that that is something
that is what happens.
Yeah.
And then, my sexual education
was lacking of course.
But then yeah,
I started talking to my girlfriends,
'cause my girlfriends and I
all super open with each other,
and I started asking them,
I was like, is this weird?
He said it was weird.
And then my friends were like,
absolutely not, fuck him.
Like, that's amazing that happened to you,
I'm so happy for you.
And you can find that with somebody
who's gonna be really excited.
But yeah, it was a weird,
I had to just feel comfortable-
Yeah.
Sharing the experience,
and feeling comfortable
talking to my friends about it.
And I think that's what I suggest
for a lot of younger women
who are starting their
like sexual journey is
talk to your friends.
As soon as I started
talking to my friends,
we have the best conversations about it.
Like it's great.
Yeah, it's great.
Yeah.
It's exactly it.
Find you fit-
Well, I mean that
that's true for us too.
I mean, I was giving you a hard time
about not telling about the butt plug,
but there's a lot of
stuff that we talked about
and encouraged each other and it's like,
oh, I discovered this
or this works for us.
Well, I just feel like in the context
I have to tell this story.
So again, this is
probably 16, 17 years ago
when me and you were MCing "Big Break."
Okay, so this is when
we were in it to win it
on the Christian missions side, right.
And so we were MCing this
conference for campus crusade
down in Panama city
and it's basically a
bunch of college students
coming together and then they
kinda go out on the beach
and try to talk to people about Jesus.
And so we're up there,
we're leading the thing,
doing our comedy stuff
in front of all them.
Does that make you horny?
And at that conference,
'cause the cool thing about
it when being on staff
is like, oh, we get to
stay in this nice hotel
and like me and Jesse get
this time together, right.
And at that time I don't think we had...
Maybe it was before we
had kids or we left a kid,
I left lock at home, I don't know.
But anyway, during that,
at that conference,
in that hotel was the first time
that we ever experienced Jesse squirting.
And again, and I had...
Even though I was a good Christian boy,
I had watched enough porn to know exactly
what had just happened.
And I was like, yes.
But yeah, so it was just
so funny that it happened
in the context of this-
And we've talked about squirting before.
Yeah.
So yeah, this thing is not news to me.
And then for me, I have this
reputation of being like,
some people might say OCD
or OCPD or like they...
And I am a clean freak and
I like things certain...
I take joy and cleaning
things, and ordering things,
and organizing things.
But when it comes to sex,
there was a decision
that I made that was...
I don't know when I made it,
but it was a long time ago.
And I think it was a
result of the conversations
that we were having.
And it was just like, you know what?
This is fun, this is an adventure,
this is a place for play.
This is a place for discovery.
It's not about...
As long as you're both on
board and you're communicating
the world is your oyster.
So that was kind of my approach.
And then saying, you know what,
there's something that I might...
My kneejerk reaction might be,
oh, this could be dirty.
Or you could see this is dirty.
Or you could see this is gross.
Well, and that was the
advice that we were getting.
So the one piece of advice that I got
from somebody who actually
talked to both of us
before we got married, who
was in our lives at the time.
Yeah.
Was...
And again, I think as much as we talk
about our Christian background,
the thing I will say is that
we did come from a particular tradition
in which even though there was
some very restrictive views
on sex and who sex could be with,
it was obviously only
between a man and a woman,
and only in the context of marriage.
That was sort of the pretense.
But-
Right.
Within that...
In the confines of that, there
wasn't a whole lot of shame.
It wasn't a shame based as
it isn't a lot of traditions.
So I'll say that.
That's why I think that we ended up having
pretty good sex lives from the beginning.
'Cause we got kind of lucky
with the specific people
we were talking to.
But one of the things that I was told
from somebody who kind
of mentored me was like,
everything's okay, but just
stay away from the butt hole.
and that was...
It was his like that was
his one piece of advice.
Yeah, that was not grounded in anything.
Yeah, so I think that that is an idea,
and that's not a Christian idea-
Yeah.
That's a cultural idea.
Yeah, so we're back to that.
But in general, I'm glad to say that
I've reaped the benefits
of checking any sort of,
I don't know what the word would be like,
just my-
Resistance.
My resistance or hesitancy
at the bedroom door
and saying, you know what,
this is a place for us
to have fun together.
And so let's be adventurous,
and let's see what we can discover.
And that that's led to a whole lot of fun.
I think my tendency is actually to
just find what works
and just go back to it.
I am a creature of habit,
if I find the right answer
or if I know where the gold nuggets are,
I'm gonna go back to that same-
Yeah.
Mine.
So the there's a...
I think there's a discipline to saying,
okay, I'm gonna keep working at this.
I'm gonna keep building
skills and experiences.
And that there's a level of commitment
and energy involved in continuing
to prioritize your sex life, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Couples, I mean exactly.
Couples have to continue
to build a dialogue
around sex, and talk.
The more people talk about it,
it becomes way more comfortable.
And you get to talk
about things all the time
to the point where it
becomes as comfortable
as talking about the weather.
You look forward to talking about sex
because you now know that
you're on the same page,
all the weird stigmas
go by and you're like,
oh, how was that for you?
You almost do like a play by play like,
last night, what'd you
think of that new thing
I did with a toy or my finger?
Oh yeah, I love this part.
Didn't love that part.
That's the world that
I want to see couples
and people living in, where it
just sex is like, of course,
we're gonna talk about
how am I gonna know?
You're not a mind reader.
I'm not a mind reader.
So yeah, I want couples
just to continue to enhance
and have these conversations
and it's gonna change everything,
'cause a couple to talk
about sex have better sex.
Well, that's one of the thing.
Yeah, nothing was more,
just to add to that.
Nothing was more amazing than
when I heard the feedback
was like, wow, that was magical.
And it felt like a mouse was
running out of a garden hose.
What?
Hey, I guess you had to be there.
I'm glad I wasn't.
So that is one of the
things that I'm really...
That I honestly think has
been a key to maintaining
21 year marriage now is...
First of all, just blessed with
just a natural communication
with Jesse that was like,
we've from the very beginning,
regardless of the
background that we're from,
we talked very openly about everything.
So the communication
has never been an issue,
which I'm just thankful for.
Great.
'Cause I know that's not an
that's not for everybody.
Right.
And then I kind of see this
sort of sexual adventure
for lack of a better word.
Just a broad term, is like,
that's one of the ways
you kind of pace out
the progression of your relationship.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like,
even today you've shown me
remote controls and stuff.
And I guess I could have told you
that those things existed specifically,
but we don't have those
things in our house.
It's a wonderful time to be alive, right?
It's a wonderful time to
be alive to know that like,
okay, you can kind of
pace these things out.
I mean, oh, we're
introducing this new thing
into our sex lives that we
can kind of enjoy for a while.
To me, that's one of the
ways that it can continues
to stay sort of vibrant and
continues to get more exciting
as you go is like pacing this stuff out,
introducing new things.
'Cause I'm the same way
and that you're like,
okay, well, which kind of
gets back to the conversation
I was going to with the missionary thing.
Somehow I've guard the reputation,
especially from Trevor,
who's one of our mythical kitchen ears
that me and Jesse are really
in the missionary sex.
And you just really thought
that was a funny joke
and then really went for it.
And the funny thing is, is
that yeah, we kind of are.
We're into a lot of things,
but I would say that that is...
If you were to see a
pie chart of all the sex
that Jesse and I have had,
the majority of the pie chart
would be in the missionary
position, right.
Well, it gets a bad rap.
What's your question?
I don't know if there's a
question here as much as,
why do you think mission...
Okay, why do you think
missionary gets a bad rap?
Missionary gets a bad rap because,
well, first it's the position
that we just kind of go
back to over and over again,
so it can get really, really boring,
and it's kind of our go to.
But there are ways to
keep it more interesting
and just spice it up.
It doesn't have to be the way
that you understand it to be,
why people...
I think just because
it's the basic position,
but you can spice it up,
like with more eye contact,
there's different ways to sit during it.
You could be sitting up where
your partner comes in like...
You could be like sitting
on the end of the bed
where your partner comes in standing.
I actually just did a podcast on this,
"Making Missionary Hot."
And I talked all about this,
there's just all these ways
that we just kind of do it the same way.
And then there's just like
different leg positions.
There's something called the cat position,
which is the Coital Alignment Technique,
where harder to explain today,
but literally it's
missionary, but your partner
on top is just sort of scooted
up a little bit further.
So you have more stimulation
on the pelvic floor area
that can actually lead to more orgasm.
So there's just like...
It gets a bad rap 'cause it's all we know,
and it's really standard.
And your partner can
just go in and pound away
like a jackhammer, but I
like to get hacks for it.
Oh.
Well, but you see
those alterations is still
missionary, 'cause I agree.
If you're facing each
other that's missionary?
If I would just-
Roughly.
I would say, yeah.
If the two bodies are facing
each other in general,
but if all of a sudden your partner
puts her legs straight up in the air
and like an L shape.
I mean, I don't know,
we gotta come up with more names I think.
And there's different
types of missionaries, man.
You've got the Mormons who
are doing like two years
in foreign countries and stuff.
Right.
You got the people like us
who are going to college campuses,
you got people who are going...
There's lots of missionaries.
The Jesuits are sending
people all over the place.
So I just think we need
to update the terminology.
I like to think of the position
when you put your legs up,
that's like a Jesuit thing,
'cause they're always kind of like...
I just feel they're on the cutting edge
a lot of times the Jesuits.
I don't know,
maybe it's just my lack of-
You think that cutting edge?
Experience with Jesuits.
But does they just seem they're
like smart and doing things.
I call it the listen to the ears.
No, I meant to say, I call
it, listen to the feet,
because the feet are by your ears.
Yeah.
It's like, what did the ear,
what are the feet saying?
What are the feet saying from right here?
Okay, Emily, this has
been very enlightening.
You've got so much knowledge-
We came to a gentle landing
with the missionary.
Well, I would say to use
the prostate analogy,
we would like to milk you
for just a few more facts,
a few more tips-
Yeah.
That didn't come out, that
didn't come out great.
But this is a safe space.
So if you could give us
three sort of parting tips,
sex tips, sex tips for
everybody that are like,
okay-
Okay.
If you can remember these three things
to take with you-
Okay.
That we haven't talked about.
Okay, so I would say
foreplay starts after the last orgasm,
meaning we foreplay all day,
continuing to keep that spark alive.
A lot of couples are like
we had sex, we did it.
And then the next time you come together,
you're like, we don't feel as connected.
So send a sexy text in
the middle of the day,
talk about your sex life,
keep sex top of mind you.
We make your sex easier.
Okay.
Can you dictate that text to me right now?
No, okay, I got it.
What's the next hot tip.
Okay.
I mean the next one would be,
I would say communication
is a lubrication.
The more we talk about sex,
the better sex we're going to have,
that would be like my time
and tone and turf stuff-
Gotcha.
Information.
And the next thing I would
say is slow everything down,
go five times slower than you think.
Sex sometimes moves way too fast,
and if we like slowly kiss our partner,
we slowly undress each other.
We move...
We just sort of put more intentionality
and more presence with our partner,
I think that we'll find a lot of us
we'll be having more successful sex.
Hmm, that's good.
Those are good words.
You should have like a show or something
where you talk about sex
because it just feels like
every time you say something
is very insightful in like based
in like grounded in
facts and evidence based.
You should really think about that.
I should, you know what, thank.
That literal hoodie thing,
you gotta gotta run with that too.
That is genius, I wrote it down.
All right, then travel pillows is mine.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm taking that with-
As long as you just send
us a couple or four,
send us four literal hoodie
when you come out with that,
that's all we ask.
Done.
Thanks so much Emily and-
Thank you for having me.
Do you have one in right now?
Just be honest.
Do I have...
I know, I don't wear
the butt plug to work,
but if you want me to start, I will.
No, no, no.
Not yet.
I'm gonna just keep asking myself.
Thank you, Emily.
Thank you so much for having me.
This was fun.
Yeah, hope you learned a lot
listener.
Well, that was fun.
It was.
I love talking about this stuff.
I don't want it to necessarily
be every single episode,
but there's just something
about saying that like,
Hey, you don't have to feel
shame and embarrassment
when you say things and
talk about these things.
Yeah.
It's not an easy thing.
It's not an easy barrier to overcome.
I love the fact that for
the second year in a row,
these conversations kind of
bring it to the forefront
of my mind and say, all right,
I'm gonna give a lot more attention to sex
and think of new things.
Be exposed to new principles techniques.
Well, you seem to be-
So yeah, I'm actually very,
I'm very excited to go home today.
I will say you took issue with me,
not telling you about
my butt plug experience,
which boy I mean.
Maybe you did, and I blocked it down.
First of all-
Maybe I wasn't ready
for first of it.
First of all, I think I
have told you about it.
Secondly, what are those people on tumbler
that think me and you
have sex with each other
gonna do about this?
How do they...
I don't think about those people.
But the thing I really wanna ask you is,
do you want me to tell you
every time I do something new?
Is that what you're asking?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
All right.
Do you want me to send
you my old butt plugs
when I upgrade to new more
technologically advanced ones?
No.
Okay.
Do you want me to tell?
You see, 'cause I mean,
I try things new too.
You're like, just because...
I mean, there's plenty of things I'll try.
I need to think about it, but.
I am up for...
I believe you man.
Every day, I'm up for more
than I was the day before.
I believe.
I'll put it to you down.
I believe you.
Thank you again to Emily
Morse, Dr. Emily Morse.
You need to listen to her podcast.
I kind of knew of her,
but I had not listened
to her actually talk about this stuff.
I've obviously listened
to some of her podcast
before she came in here
and I was just like, man,
I should be listening to
this on a regular basis.
And just a couple of episodes,
I felt like I was like, man,
like this is-
They missing out.
I'm a man who has sex with my wife
and I just feel like
there's this treasure trove
of information.
But she doesn't just have sex with Emily,
she actually just did a MasterClass.
Oh yeah, like officially
in the MasterClass
subscription service.
Yeah, yeah.
You can check that out.
So she teaches the MasterClass thing
and also lots of resources
and more information about
Emily @sexwithemily.com.
When you're taking your
toddlers to the playground,
bring your jambox and play
sex with Emily's podcast.
I suggest doing it with headphones on-
All right.
And make sure
that it's going into the headphones
and not coming outta your phone.
A lot of times you don't realize
that it's coming outta the phone.
It's just, you might be a mixed company.
We got another special guest
coming up on the next
episode, Emily Nagoski,
author of the book-
We only speak with Emily's
when we talk about this-
"Come As You Are."
Great book.
She is a doctor?
Yes, she is a doctor.
Dr. Emily Nagoski.
Only Dr. Emily's.
And we are going to be speaking with her.
And then week after
that, we're gonna be...
We're gonna open it up to any questions,
any sort of...
I don't know exactly what the prompt is.
We'll figure that out.
What do we say?
It'll be on the...
It'll be online.
Of course, go ahead and leave a voicemail.
Let us know what you
think about this episode,
we love your responses.
1-888-earpod1.
Earpod1.
And of course, you can use #EarBiscuits.
So we'll speak at you next
week's "Sex Timber" continues.
Timber.
It elongates
through the whole month.
Hey, there Rhett and Link.
This is Kaylee from Michigan.
I'm watching your "Ride a Hole" episode,
and you're trying to figure out
why young people watch podcasts
instead of listening to podcasts.
I mean, I'm 25.
I feel like I'm in the young demographic.
When I am watching a podcast,
it is because if I listen to it,
I will start thinking about other things,
and then miss potentially
like 20 to 30 minutes
of the podcast.
And then I have to like
rewind and re-listen to it.
So I have an on, on my TV,
like in my home while I
go and do other things
like cook dinner or
clean things, or like...
I'm a teacher, so I'll like grade things.
And then I have something to look up to
and it kind of like reenters the listening
and then I don't miss anything.
But I don't just sit and
watch it like a movie
it's just like on in the background.
So I'm listening technically
like a regular podcast,
but my eyes have something to focus on.
Don't know if everyone does it this way,
but that is why I do it this way.
Thanks so much, bye.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
This is Yesi from Florida.
I just finished listening to lock,
going to a university in
Florida and I wish him the best.
I'm from Miami,
so University of Miami
Hurricanes was in my childhood.
I graduated from the
University of Florida,
so I'm a Florida Gator and I
married a man who is an SSU,
Florida State University Seminole fan.
So Florida baby through and through.
Bye guys, love you.
Hey guys, this Leslie.
The truck driver going to
Nevada as usual every week.
Thank you for everything you guys do.
Totally love your biscuits.
Never knew that in my 40s and early 50s,
I would be a groupie for
the first time in my life,
but I totally am your groupie.
Love you guys.
Thank you for everything you do,
cannot wait till mythical guys.
I don't care if I get six feet
from you, 100 feet from you,
it'll be awesome to see
you and to see the crew.
Bye.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.